in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kevin
and Jordan are with us hey how are you
doing good
welcome welcome good to have you guys
having us where do you live
Kansas City Missouri cool welcome to
Nashville thank you have you so you're
here to do your debt-free scream we are
excited how much have you paid off paid
off one hundred twenty-three thousand
dollars and 36 months way to go biking
what kind of money we started off at
about 110 and now we're up to 165 Wow
what do you guys do for a living I'm in
marketing and not an engineering very
good good for you guys so what kind of
debt was the hundred and twenty three
thousand it was all mortgage all nowhere
help your house stayed off the house
we're really excited we're home %
debt-free I love it
how old are you do we're in our south
30s south thirties I'm 31 she's 32 how
thirties that's good I like that that's
a new one all right so you know paid for
house yeah what's this house worth about
165 Wow
how does that feel you're so weird yeah
we enjoy being weird so it's it's very
exciting something that we've been
looking forward to for awhile and we're
hoping to continue to build on this in
the future if we want to move in the
future we want to do it cash free or
cash only yeah did you what did you did
you have a mortgage burning party in the
backyard yeah no no warmer maybe yeah
yeah very cool so tell me your story
what happened 36 months ago that puts
you on this journey well you know I've
been listening to you for a while and we
kind of just got to the point you know
we had purchased some new or new to us
vehicles and we got to the point where
really wanted to start tackling our
mortgage said I had just got done
getting a master's degree that we cash
flowed and we decided we wanted to
started being more we wanted to start
being more aggressive and so we just
kicked that off and December of 2012 and
my wife has been very gracious her last
four bonuses have all gone towards also
mortgage so every December for the last
four years and so she's been an absolute
huge help on that so I just want to give
her props but we just started throwing
everything we could at it and just
knocked it down slowly and surely and
we've had two kiddos since then we have
Lydia who's a three year old and Gideon
who's one years
they're watching at home with the
grandparents so we wanted to say hi to
them awesome very cool these kiddos are
living in a debt-free house yes and I
don't think that I don't think that
means anything to them
no because their family tree is changed
I mean it's amazing where you can go now
with this kind of income and as young as
you all are oh my goodness that's so
much money Wow
you're gonna be able to give and you're
gonna be able to do anything you want to
do I mean this is amazing
congratulations yeah you got to take
your shoes off when it gets a little
warmer walk through the backyard the
grass feels different when you own it
yeah I'll tell you that's a different
deal right there yeah well
congratulations you guys so what was the
hardest part of this for the two of you
I think for uh well I'll speak for
myself in the sense that what my
employer has been able to give us a cash
bonus every year and I think a hard part
was you know you watch that money coming
to your bank account and we would sit
and talk and like oh we could spend this
on something fun or we could put it
towards the house and that seems very
intangible and it's kind of frustrating
sometimes but you know it's the adult
and best thing to do and so you know
sometimes we'd say well we'll splurge on
three I think we bought a guest bed for
my parents to come visit you know spend
$300 and then the rest went towards the
house and so it just it just that's hard
because you wanted you know you hear
about what all your co-workers fun
things your co-workers are buying and no
new couch oh we've you know whatever
lots of cool clothes and chipped away at
our mortgage mm-hmm and so that was not
hard but just sort of the what we
decided to do with it and stuck with it
so I guess now the next time it comes up
the break room you'll just have to go
yeah paid off the house response from
her co-workers on this so now they're
looking to hurt for financial advice
Kevin really champion for us like he was
very gracious he's definitely the much
we're all we're both sort of naturally
frugal but he's the person that really
planned it out he had the spreadsheet he
had the engineer really yeah
I know right and I am sort of I'm I'm
you know I'm sort of naturally frugal
but definitely much more of the Spree
feared I didn't our free spirit I don't
want to be boxed in I don't want money
in an envelope you know like I just I
needed a more gentle touch to be on
board with this and Kevin was very
gracious and gave me that and we
actually have a I think one of our
pictures has a the chart that I
requested Kevin make for us um so he had
a formula in a spreadsheet that showed
how much our payment would be to tick
off you know the mortgage in the right
increments and I said you know what'd be
really great is every time we made a
normal payment you know we marked off
the month that it was for but any time
we put something extra on it you know we
backed it out of whatever we did and I'm
a very visual person and so he said hey
yeah I can make that for you and so that
chart hung in our pantry so I looked at
it every day I don't know every month we
would get together with a pin and mark
off the regular payment and then it was
really great especially when we put the
bonus on it we were marking off 11
months at a time
yeah or 13 months at a time and so that
was a really great visual way for me to
see the traction we were making and it
may be easier to swallow
there's our chart now you know what is
the most impressive thing is the way you
two have worked together the way you've
taken each other's differences and you
both said about each other how gracious
you are I mean you this has really
caused you all to focus on you know the
relationally to do this to pull this off
I mean that that's the that's the big
takeaway here yeah you're gonna be rich
but that's main reason you are the
second reason is because you paid off
your house and you know you really are
you're gonna get to do fun stuff
anything you want to do I mean because
you've got you don't have any baby you
don't have any payments I mean this is
incredible the math on this will blow
your mind when you do it do it do one
more chart again yeah sure where this is
going does it mean just if you just save
your house payment until you're 45 just
do that in a mutual fund that's gonna be
millions of dollars just that alone
we've talked about that and that's it's
a little untenable for some people I
won't name I won't say who well that's
why you need a chart we already covered
this right tangible tangible
good I like tangible I'm on Jordans side
very good well you guys are incredible
I'm so proud of you you're rock stars
this is amazing Kevin and Jordan Kansas
City house and everything a hundred and
twenty three thousand dollars paid off
in 36 months making a hundred one
hundred and ten up to 165 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one well done well done well done
good job you guys man that's awesome hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you are not a victim you're not a victim
of big corporations you're not a victim
of Wall Street you're not a victim of
capitalism you're not a victim of wealth
inequality you're not a victim of racism
you're not a victim